the fact that the object represented
becomes the property of pure
self-consciousness its elevation to
universality in general is only one
aspect of formative education not its
fulfillment the manner of study in
ancient times differed from that of the
modern age and that the former was the
proper and complete formation of the
natural consciousness putting itself to
the test at every point of its existence
and philosophizing about everything I
came across it made itself into a
universality that was active through and
through in modern times however the
individual finds the abstract form
ready-made the effort to grasp and
appropriate it is more the direct
driving forth of what is within and the
truncated generation of the universal
than it is the emergence of the latter
from the concrete variety of existence
hence the task today consists not so
much in purging the individual of an
immediate sensuous mode of apprehension
and making him into a substance that is
a object of thought and that thinks but
rather than just the opposite in freeing
determinate thoughts from their fixity
so as to give actuality to the universal
and to impart to its spiritual life but
it is far harder to bring fixed thoughts
into a fluid state then to do so with
sensuous existence the reason for this
was given above fixed thoughts have the
I the power of the negative or pure
actuality for the substance an element
to their existence where is sensuous
determinations have only powerless
abstract immediacy or being as such
thoughts become fluid when pure thinking
this inner immediacy recognizes itself
as a moment or when the pure certainty
of self abstract from itself not by
leaving itself out or setting itself
aside but by giving up the fixity if
it's self positing by giving up not only
the fixative the pure concrete
which the eye itself is in contrast with
its undifferentiated content but also
the fixity of the differentiated moments
which positive in the element of pure
thinking share the unconditioned nature
of the eye through this movement that
pure thoughts become notions and are
only now what they are in truth self
movements circles spiritual essences
which is what their substance is
so in section 33 we're following up on
what happened in section 32 in Section
32 we saw that through the power of the
understanding through the power of the
negative human being as consciousness is
able to you might say tear itself out or
extricate itself to a strange itself
from the matrix of what it was engaged
and analyzing and it begins to realize
that it is something over and against
and thereby mediating with what it is
that it understands what it comes to
know and Hegel says the fact that the
object represented becomes a property
that is belongs to well you know it is a
possession of pure self consciousness
that makes it into something Universal
when I thank camera for example I have
this camera in particular but I also
have a conception of camera and I
understand what a camera does and I can
compare this camera against you know the
notion or the universal conception of
camera I have that that's something that
is in relation me in relation to that
that's part of that mediation within
myself to outward objects and and also
within myself making sense of things
so Hegel says look you've got this whole
process of development that's been
taking place in which it gets more and
more integrated more and more complex
that's part of what he calls building
performative education now if we look at
a world spirit as developing through
history we have one single process of
this or you can also call it culture and
yet every single generation also has to
approach this and appropriate it for
itself that's part of the process of
becoming uncultured
of becoming a person within a given time
who is not just an abstract isolated
moment but who is able to benefit from
this
this past to appropriate it to oneself
so the question is how do we do that in
the modern period as opposed to the
ancient period here he's gonna have
another contrast that he's already begun
to unpack before he says the manner of
studying ancient times differed from
that of the modern age in that the
former was the proper and complete
formation of the natural consciousness
natural consciousness is you know what
begins at any given a POC so for example
taking taking an iPad as something
that's just part of our landscape it's
part of the natural consciousness for
you know anybody who's say 21 and down
at this point maybe you know we have to
adjust that upward I don't want to get
into the little quibbles about that but
you see what I'm saying there for me a
cellphone is something different than it
is for my children because I remember a
time when phones were for the most part
rotary and you know had cords and plot
you know they were generally plugged
into the wall and then you got the
touch-tone ones and eventually cordless
phones you know what a liberation that
was those are all parts of the natural
consciousness of any given point in time
another example you know a contemporary
example would be paying at the pump you
know that was a weird thing for me for a
while
in parkas that wasn't part of that
wasn't an aspect of my natural
consciousness our natural consciousness
is our way of being in the world at any
given time so when we're looking at
ancient cultures and how they developed
culture that was then transmitted
there's a natural consciousness and what
natural consciousness does is it just
puts itself to the test at every point
of its existence and philosophize
everything that it comes across so it
runs into things and this is what the
hell is this what's that what's this
let me taste this let me try this and
he's not talking about every single
human being at this point he's talking
about the people who are making progress
in ancient times you know should i
attack that guy I don't know I'm kind of
scared of dying but let's see what it's
like that's a part of this process that
he's talking about putting itself into
the things that it's studying the
putting itself into its test it made
itself into a universality that was
active through and through so starting
out from what we can call abstract being
immediacy sensuousness sensuousness II
doesn't mean something like you know
erotic or anything like that what he
means is being being a being in the
world that we perceive with our senses
that we make sense of and then stripping
ourselves away from a complete reliance
so Plato for example in conceiving of
form as being something distinct from
matter and saying that there was a world
of the forms that was more real was
tearing himself away from purely
sensuous existence but so is anybody who
threw themselves into battle and risked
will see why when we get to later
discussions in phenomenology so what is
the achievement their universality
making something fixed because you know
this the immediate the sensuous those
are like all over the map it's this you
know as William James called a booming
buzzing confusion and what took place in
ancient culture was making things be
what they were that was an achievement
in Hegel's view so he says it made
itself into a universality that was
active through and through in modern
times in our times the individual finds
the abstract form what it was that was
achieved through hard
work through labor through generations
in the past they find this this abstract
form ready-made the effort to grasp and
appropriate it is more of the direct
driving forth of what is within and the
truncated generation of the universal
than it is the emergence of the ladder
from the concrete variety and existence
so we have the products of this process
of developing culture and our our
tendency is to take them for granted as
being fixed things to lose sight of what
was actually attained what was achieved
in that process and to treat them as
mere things even to treat them as mere
commodities you know this is not you
know something entirely new to the
moderns Lucian I think I may have
mentioned this in another video has this
wonderful satire about the book buyer
the person who stocks their library with
all these books never reads them and
thinks that by having the inert objects
there they somehow possess the knowledge
which is something active something
dynamic that's contained in those books
that's a danger for us text books are
particularly bad for that I think that a
lot of popularization zuv things have a
tendency to to do that as well for us so
he says the test nowadays is not so much
purging the individual of an immediate
sensuous mode of apprehension and making
that individual into a substance that's
that's capable of thinking about
themselves and that can fix themselves
into something but rather it's just the
opposite we start out with these
determinate fixed thoughts and what's
really underlying them we're going to
see is the the abstract while the the
concrete the purely concrete by that is
you know within all of us
so he says freeing determinate thoughts
from their fixity so as to get actually
to the universal and to a part to its
spiritual and you've got this
capitalized life why do I have life
capitalized well what is life
life is a process of ongoing becoming of
appropriating of integrating of choosing
of making distinctions it's active it's
not something passive that takes in
these fixed thoughts and then just sort
of processes them and you know uses some
sort of algorithm to make sense of them
know what we have to recover is this
sense of activity in actuality that's
what's what's that loss that's what we
miss in the modern period Hegel thinks
that we need more of that kind of
negativity
so he says fixed thoughts have the I the
power of the negative appear II
actuality for the substance and element
of their existence that's what makes
them tougher to unfix because that's
tougher then abstract being is a metric
being for Hegel is just well you know
you walk around and you encounter things
and there they are and you know you can
get to know them a little bit now this
we bring with us everywhere and in the
modern period we've become aware of
ourselves as this pure I through the
cart through hobbes through cons through
our conceptions of freedom through our
very you know view that it's important
for us to figure out who we are and to
determine ourselves Hegel is getting at
that makes it more likely for us to take
on these fixed thoughts as fix things
and not bring back to them the fluidity
that they really need and how do we do
that well by reflecting upon ourselves
that's what this process of spiritual
life is so he says thoughts become fluid
when pure thinking this inner immediacy
recognizes itself not
the be-all and end-all that has a moment
remember how we talked about moments
being part of a whole recognizes itself
as a moment or when the pure certainty
of the self of stratts from itself not
by leaving itself out not by setting
itself aside because it's important it's
part of the big picture but by giving up
its fixity of its self positing so you
know if we want to use Descartes for
example imagine if Descartes said you
know maybe I am more than just thinking
substance maybe some weird way my body
does matter to me more which by the way
he actually read the letters to Princess
Elizabeth and the passions of the soul
and you'll see the beginnings of that as
merleau-ponty recognized so he says by
giving up not only the fixity of the
pure concrete which the eye itself is
but also the fixity of the
differentiated moments which posited in
the element of pure thinking share this
unconditioned nature of the eye we have
to be willing to learn what it means to
be an eye to be a subject that means
that we have to stop taking so many
things for granted that doesn't mean
that we like forget everything or we
react in some pure vacuum where nobody
knows anything but rather we have to be
willing to allow things to be as active
as they are and to see our own role in
contributing to what they are that's
difficult that takes work so he says
through this molt through this movement
pure thoughts become notions or concepts
that Griffith that's what the process of
the phenomenology is charting out he
says now they are what they are in truth
self movements circles spiritual
essences which is what their substance
is so when we actually do that when we
carry out this process of formative
education and we get away from just
relying on determinate fixed thoughts
and start moving towards notions we're
going to encounter them and they're
going to encounter us and they're going
to have a kind of agency because they
possess a sort of like he says self
movement that's scary for a lot of
people the good news is of course that
we're going to see that they're actually
reflections of ourselves but we're not
going to see that right away
this movement of pure essences
constitutes the nature of scientific
method in general regarded as the
connectedness of their content it is the
necessary expansion of the content into
an organic whole through this movement
the path by which the notion of
knowledge is reached becomes likewise a
necessary and complete process of
becoming so that this preparatory path
ceases to be a casual philosophizing
that fastens on to this or that object
relationship or thought that happens to
pop up in the imperfect consciousness or
tries to base the truth on the pros and
cons the inferences and consequences
originally defined thoughts instead this
pathway through the movement of the
notion will encompass the entire sphere
of secular consciousness in its
necessary development
in this section number 34 and in the
very short section 35 that falls Hegel's
kind of bringing things together now
there's this constant ebb and flow you
know introduce new notions or new ways
of looking at things
consolidate them together yeah so now
he's going to return to talking about
scientific method which is how Miller is
translating this long German word this
inshaa fleet kite this is shaft you know
we've talked about this plenty that
means science leak is like kites the
state of the the condition of so the
condition of actually being scientific
of being along the lines of science what
is that now when we that the reason I
bring that up is I don't want you when
you see method to immediately think back
to chemistry class or biology class or
Natural Science and think a lot of the
scientific method as you know we were
taught back then because remember
science is something broader for Hegel
because it has to encompass the human it
has to encompass the person who's coming
to know the person who's conceptualizing
and make you know that part of the
process as well and that's part of the
that's one thing that science in the
sense that we think of that today
doesn't really do adequately and doesn't
teach people how to do well enough so
his his notion of scientific method is
going to be a bit different and he says
this movement of pure essences
constitutes the nature of scientific
method in general so what is he talking
about there this is referring back to
the previous section the movement of
pure essences or thoughts that we're
finishing up with at the end these were
fixed and they have to be transmuted
into notions into the griffa into
concepts into some sort of sort of
dynamic thing and this becomes instead
of just a movement which is you know
being carried out upon them it has to
become a self movement that's part of
what makes them notions so he says this
movement of pure essences constitutes
the nature of scientific method in
general there's something about the
systematic the integrating function of
science that gets us to move away from
fixed thoughts that we just take for
granted as being familiar and look at
them and allow them to come to life as
dynamic wholes dynamic concepts dynamic
notions so he says if we think about
this in terms of the connectedness of
their content the the fact that each one
of these things that we're studying is
connected with the other things that
there's no you might say scientific
hermetically sealed containers with
biology over here and physics over here
and history over here with nothing to do
with each other if we reject that sort
of notion and we say actually these
things aren't connected with each other
once we start realizing that
connectedness that moves us towards
looking to try to have some sort of
organic whole so these are words that
again to use you know the the D
familiarization we really ought to spend
a little bit of time D familiarizing
ourselves from organic whole because
people often talk in terms of holism or
things being organic there's sort of a
rise Hegel doesn't actually mean it in
that sense he thinks that this is going
to be differentiated complex ly
connected together it's going to be
articulate it's not going to be some
vague you know loosey-goosey sort of
thing it's gonna be very rigorous so he
says through this movement the path by
which the notion of knowledge
is reached becomes a necessary and
complete process of becoming so there's
two elements they're necessary that
means that we can actually sort of
follow it out and say this needs to come
from here it's not necessary in the
sense of logic you know the logic that
we're used to teaching in the school is
a formal logic rather it follows its own
developing logic that can only be seen
from the vantage point of seeing it once
it's developed that's where the
completeness comes in but notice that
he's talking about the notion of
knowledge the McGriff the conception of
knowledge knowledge itself is not a
simple relation of me to the content I'm
actually included within that concept as
the knower of that and that in term that
what it is that's being known is going
to be incorporated into me that's what
mediation which he's not actually using
the term for here that's going to come
into play in this sort of thing we
should always think mediation when we're
reading Hegel we should always think
that there's always connections between
things so he says this preparatory path
ceases to be a casual philosophizing
that fastens on this or that object
again we see this this emphasis on D
familiarization not just taking whatever
happens to come along whatever our age
happens to tell us everything is all
about if we actually a historical
perspective we realized that's very
arbitrary what we want is to grasp
what's really essential to human beings
human development to that to the march
of spirit not just what our age at this
point in time in this place with this
discourse happens to tell us and we
happen to digest and assimilate and
assume and then you know regurgitate
back out those good consumers of
information we want to exercise a little
bit more responsibility and care because
that's part of
what it means to realize the
potentiality of human being not just to
have knowledge in the sense of having
accumulated a lot of things in your head
or even some you know vague notion of
being able to apply it but actually
being able to conceptualize in a
rigorous systematic way that takes you
into account and places you in human
history what this knowledge business is
about so he says we want to get away
from just casual philosophizing that
fastens on this or that object
relationship or thought that happens to
pop up or tries to base the truth on the
pros and cons the inferences and
consequences originally defined thoughts
instead what we're looking at is the
movement of the notion the movement of
the concept and again we you know we can
talk about this in terms of like the
march all the way through history up to
Hegel's time or we can think about it in
terms of something that every single
generation faces is part of the
necessity to to re-appropriate
reassimilate and thereby learn what it
means to be fully human to make
themselves part of that movement of the
notion so Hegel sees these two things as
intimately connected the movement of the
notion through history through these
these stages of consciousness is really
about developing knowledge now that may
strike you is really weird that you wait
a second so wars are somehow about
knowledge so economic processes are
about knowledge so you know the
interplay between divine law and human
law or the family and the state those
are all about knowledge those seem like
really practical matters having to do
with action with choice with values with
decision Hegel would say well actually
that's all still part of knowledge
insofar as it's the human being trying
to come to know themselves and things
like the good the just the
our parts of that movement towards
knowledge so he says this is going to
encompass the entire sphere of secular
that is veldt lika consciousness in its
necessary development so everything
that's taken place in the world these
are very ambitious isn't it you think
that's taking place at least the
essential things through human history
have to be brought into this as part of
the movement of the notion and as part
of what goes into knowledge now you know
Hegel in 1807 he had a much easier
vantage point than perhaps we do this is
one of those points where you might say
yeah I don't know if I'm going to buy
into the whole hey galleon the whole
headed galleon stick the whole Hegelian
picture of what's going on because a lot
has happened since Hegel but the
question that you could ask yourself
then is well is Hegel's basic approach
able to to say okay new things have
developed since then new shapes of
consciousness they've taught us
something about about knowing that goes
beyond where I was able to be could we
chart that up and then reincorporate
that that would be the question that
you'd want to ask but what he's talking
about here is what it means to really be
scientific once again